ونخصص هذا الجزء للعمل الانساني في فلسطين
واسمحوا لي ان استضيف رئيس منظمه اغاثه
اطفال فلسطين ستيفا سوسيبي ستيف كان صحفيا
امريكيا بارزا قرر ان يكرس حياته لاطفال
فلسطين واسس هذه المنظمه قبل عقود ليس هذا
فقط ستيف لكن اعتقد ايضا انه علاقتك
بفلسطين تتعدى ذلك ما هي علاقتك سر علاقتك
بفلسطين
لقد
[موسيقى]
ذهبت الى فلسطين خلال الانتفاضه الاولى
بصفه طالبا حصلت وقتها على فرصه ان اكون
ضمن بعثه حقوقيه الى جانب طلبات اخرين
لاعاين بنفسي الوضع في الضفه الغربيه وغزه
كانوا عرضه للقتل والسجن وكانت منازلهم
عرضه للتدمير ولكن في نفس الوقت كانوا
اناسا شجعانا جدا
وبصفه اثارتني حيث انهم كانوا على درجه
كبيره من الانسانيه بما جعلني مرتبطا جدا
بهم على مستوى انساني بحت
لقد شعرت بصفه امريكيا وبدرجه قويه بانه
علي
واجب ومسؤوليه دعم الشعب الفلسطيني
وعندما عدت لاحقا واصبحت صحفيا واتولى
تغطيه الانتفاضه قبلت اطفالا اصيبوا ومنهم
من فقدوا رجولهم وكانوا بحاجه الى الرعايه
الطبيه
بدات بنقلهم الى مستشفيات امريكيه بالمجان
لقد وفرنا ذلك لاكثر من 2000 طفلا من
فلسطين ولكن ايضا من سوريا والعراق ومن
لبنان ولان مظهر لهم اننا نهتم لامرهم
واننا نحب اطفال فلسطين وانهم غير منسيين
وكنت متزوج بفلسطينيه
او هدى كنت متزوجا من هدى المصري والدها
من القدس ووالدتها من رمل كنت اول امريكي
يتزوج لاجئه فلسطينيه داخل فلسطين اثناء
الانتفاضه كنا متزوجين لمده 17 عاما ثم
توفيت عام 2009 بالسرطان